bless me Father for I have sinned it's
been too long since my last confession
I've been preoccupied of late with
questions of morality right I'm wrong
good and evil perhaps this will be
easier if you tell me what you've done
I'm not seeking forgiveness what I've
done father I'm asking forgiveness for
what I'm about to do
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie that's gonna
be my breakdown of the daredevil Netflix
trailer is dropping April 10th are
dropping all the episodes at once it's
based on the Frank Miller john romita
jr. comic Man Without Fear they give it
is like arrow season 3 on steroids okay
starting out we're just going to go shot
by shot so the primary location for this
is going to be Hell's Kitchen because of
the time line with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe this will take place probably
before Avengers age of Ultron so this is
post attack on New York the comic is a
little bit different he grew up in
Hell's Kitchen went away to college and
then went to Boston so Boston is the
primary location of the comic but in the
TV series is it's all going to be in
Hell's Kitchen part of what's going on
in this trailer is explaining daredevil
for people that have never read
daredevil before don't know that he's
blind don't know that he works as a
lawyer don't know who the other
characters are so we started in present
day in the monastery he's giving a
confessional saying I'm not asking for
forgiveness for what I've done I'm
asking forgiveness for what I'm about to
do so he's getting ready to take on the
daredevil persona this is an origin
story so they're gonna tell that I just
I don't know how many episodes they'll
spend on it or how many flashbacks we'll
see they might just get through that in
the first episode but we do know that
he's not going to put on the red
daredevil costume till the very end of
the series it's 13 episodes total so
just just to give you a timeline it's
going to be about 13 episodes before we
see that rate costume that's why we see
him in the black costume that came
before the red daredevil costume he
didn't even call himself daredevil to
the end of the story and The Man Without
Fear at the comic book they might play
it fast and loose in the TV show with
that they've changed a few characters
Elektra is a big part of the comic but
presumably she's not in season one of
the TV show but yes they will be doing
season two so this isn't a limited time
thing they're gonna keep doing daredevil
seasons as long as it's successful as
long as it still makes money the
significance of the church in the
daredevil mythos is it it is just
something of a haven for him where he
can come clear his mind like neutral
territory Hell's Kitchen is a lot like
Starling city on arrow it just overrun
with crime so he like Oliver Queen on
that series decides he wants to clean up
his city actually I think the glades is
a better analogy right now in arrow
season 3 so Hell's Kitchen in daredevil
is gonna be a lot like the clades
Vincent D'Onofrio kingpin is gonna be a
lot like Vinnie Joneses break although
Vincent D'Onofrio is like a thousand
times better I'm being a little biased
but vincent said
a froyo is a great actor and kingpin is
a much better character than brick fun
fact Marc Guggenheim the showrunner on
arrow is actually writing a daredevil
one-shot comic book that's going to be
out soon I'll be sure to mention it in a
video whenever it comes out I just think
it's funny that the showrunner on a DC
TV show also writes a lot of Marvel
comic books so we get a good shot at
Charlie Cox's Matt Murdock I thought it
was kind of weird when I first heard he
was cast I do like his other stuff so
I'll be real interested to see how he
fits into this Marvel action based world
one of the good things is is based on
the past treatments of daredevil on
screen there's nowhere to go but up
anything they do will be better than
what's come before so I'm wildly
optimistic he's blind as everyone
probably knows but he uses echolocation
he has like a enhanced version of
echolocation it's not really a
superpower but it's the next best thing
so we're just seeing his perspective now
this is what it'll look like at least in
the light of day that's why he uses the
cane in the Escrima sticks so when he
bangs on stuff it helps him with
echolocation it helps his visual cortex
map stuff out deborah ann woll is
playing Karen page she ends up working
at Matt Murdock's law firm and become
something of a love interest for him so
she's like the love interest of the
series based on the work that she's done
before and based on the lack of Elektra
in the series I'm wondering if they're
gonna give her some some badass fight
scenes by the end of this series but as
we can see right now she kind of starts
out on hard time so she's probably not
gonna start out being a badass this is
Elden Henson he's playing foggy Nelson
he's Matt Murdock's partner in the
comics his partner and his law firm he's
not really a Diggle type character he's
not a fighter but he does try to help
Matt Murdock the daredevil stuff gets a
little more complicated i don't know
like full-on spoil that if you haven't
read the comic yet but they do end up in
something of a love triangle with Karen
page it wouldn't be a drama without a
love triangle the first time I saw this
I thought it was a flashback for Matt
Murdock his father got killed by the mob
for not throwing a fight it looks more
like Karen pages origin story someone
close to her ends up getting murdered so
she seeks out Matt Murdock's legal help
but because of the nature of the crime
she ends up crossing paths with
daredevil just because of the mob
presence in Hell's Kitchen it's one of
those situations where the mob commits
crimes the people come to Matt Murdock
for legal help and persecuting them and
that daredevil ends up cleaning the mess
up at night this is scott glenn who's
playing stick he's the one who trains
Matt Murdock to fight
also blind he's one that trains him to
like run across the rooftops and be a
badass this over here is Hachiro they
haven't really explained his character
he is not in the comic book but because
they presumably are leaving Electra out
for a future season they might be adding
him in an Electra type role but he does
look kind of sinister Electra's kind of
a sinister character herself in the
comics at least for a little while here
is Vincent D'Onofrio as the kingpin
they're actually the interesting thing
about this series is that as much as
this an origin story for daredevil it's
also going to be an origin story for
kingpin they're actually going to spend
a lot of time telling his story I think
it's white Vincent D'Onofrio was so
attracted to doing a character like this
the owner of this place is his love
interest the owner of the art gallery
she ends up dying really horribly and it
serves as a big call to action for him I
think I was just talking about narrative
symmetry in my flash video my flash
episode video from last night so you're
gonna see the rise of daredevil you'll
see the rise of kingpin to it makes me
really excited for season two this is
rosario Dawson she's playing Claire
temple I know a lot of people thought
she might be playing electra Claire
temple is just a nurse who works at
night and helps Matt Murdock helps patch
him up this here just based on the way
that they've cut this into the trailer
it looks like it might be his first
night wearing the mask very much a
Batman year one situation and here we
just get a really awesome fight sequence
so he's gonna be parkouring the [ __ ] at
everyone we see the Escrima sticks like
I said he needs to bang on stuff he
needs to create noise to use his
echolocation abilities because of the
budget they're working with I would
think of this is like a souped-up
version of the stunts on arrow arrow has
some of the best stunts of any of the
superhero TV shows but it has a really
small budget because Marvel went to
Netflix with this and because Marvel's
Disney they have unlimited money they
had they have some extra juice to throw
at it so just remember this is going to
be 13 episodes they're going to dump
them all on April 10th I have no idea
how I'm going to do videos for all of
them I might do one video per episode
just because they're going to be
hour-long episodes usually it's a little
easier for me to organize stuff whenever
I do things one at a time however it's
going to happen I'll be doing videos for
the entire series they're going to be
making more announcements about it when
it gets a little bit closer but this
will be like their lead in into Avengers
2 along with agents of shield so I think
what they're hoping is is that you
finish this series before Avengers 2
starts I'm really excited about it if
you're not familiar the show
is Steven denied he worked on spartacus
blood and sand the funny thing about
that is the air on the flash steal a lot
of actors from Spartacus or actors that
were on Spartacus so there's a lot of
like Marvel DC meta crossover going on
here in the in the show running universe
between Vancouver and Los Angeles
doesn't that make you wonder if we're
ever gonna c minus bennett like Slade
Wilson on daredevil at some point I
don't think that's going to happen but
it just is funny to think about for
those that are asking i'm gonna try to
post my agent Carter episode 5 video my
my Howling Commandos video before arrow
starts tonight if I don't get it out in
time I'll just push it out Thursday
morning so don't worry I am working on
an agent Carter episode 5 video so if
you guys haven't read that comic book
and you want to you can actually get
Marvel unlimited it's like ninety nine
dollars a year you can read almost every
comic the marmots ever published but I
might also give away a couple copies of
the comic whenever we get closer to this
series so be sure to subscribe to get
all that stuff don't forget arrow
tonight it's a good template for what
the stunts are going to look like on
daredevil if you do want to learn more
about the comic book you can click here
for my breakdown of The Man Without Fear
storyline and you can click here to get
ready for arrow tonight thank you so
much watching so it's all high five I'll
see you guys a little bit
you